are you Jessica hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up all
right so this is he wanted off three
years but and I've read the Total Money
Makeover book my husband is not a fan I
put that out there first but we have
some serious debt and it's all pretty
much you don't loan debt from my husband
going to law school and so right now we
are in an income based repayment plan
which so we haven't really been worried
about this debt because after all after
like 20 or 25 years it'll be forgiven
quote-unquote but I happen to look at
one of the balance statements a cop like
a few weeks ago
and it's gone from 100 one hundred and
ninety thousand instead loans at 250,000
and student loan debt and so because of
the interest and so I'm kind of I'm
starting to panic because I just mmm
sorry I don't know how to get out of it
[Music]
what's your household sorry
okay what's your household income my
husband he makes ninety thousand a year
and when your service you know we I was
gonna say you know we bought into this
sort of idea that a lawyers going to
make a lot of money and so it wasn't a
big deal to take the school loans out
but he's basically he started working
public right out of law school and then
you know his his salaries increased over
the last four years about 60 grand but
it's still obviously not gonna put a
dent in the school loan issue so how old
is he 35 35 so when you say he's not a
fan you mean he's not a fan of getting
out of debt it's not that he's yeah I'm
not sure I don't know exactly why he he
doesn't care for your program
that's not the getting out of debt part
I think he doesn't want to think about
these school loans and I don't think she
wants to I think part of our problem is
that we don't know what to do about it
and so we see beans and rice like I've
cut our budget because I do listen and
so I've cut our budget down and we don't
have cable we don't have a lot of the
extras or cell phone bill is like less
than $80 a month for both of us because
his work pays part of his and I mean so
I tried to cut down in all the areas
that I can and you know in food and all
those things I mean what you're not
saving money and you're not paying extra
on the debt so you're not doing a rig
that way you're not doing a written plan
for every dollar you're just cutting
stuff I'm cutting stuff this is the
first month because of I looked at it a
few months ago knows there are a few
weeks ago and start listening to you
again this is the first month where I've
really done the budget out so that we're
gonna have and we have about eleven
hundred dollars extra a month after all
of our bills are paid that's do you have
so the school loans and then we we've
had we've had a camper for a few years
so that's like 13 just under 14,000 on
that and then we had bought a truck last
year to pull the camper and then we owe
38,000 on that but we don't have any
credit card debt or anything like that
but so you just guys you know I know
you're scared but you just keep doing
stupid stuff well yeah you know so I'm
hopeless about getting out of debt and
so I'm not gonna willing to listen to
anybody I'm putting words in his mouth
so let's go by $38,000 truck top pull on
camper Wow
well part of the thing was I wanted to
sell our house last year I actually
wanted to live in a camper we homeschool
and I wanted to be able to you know rode
school and kind of do some not stuff so
the idea that was that we were gonna
sell the house and then we were gonna we
were going to live in the camper and
then that all changed because
wasn't ready to do that but we had we
bought the truck in anticipation of that
so yeah we're not the I feel like we're
smart people but financially not doing
super smart things and then we bought a
new house discussed because we sold our
house but there's a lot there's a lot
you guys can't get on the same page and
so depending on whether he wants to slap
his foot down or not you guys are
lurching back and forth from stupid
thing to stupid thing because you don't
have do not have it do not have a clear
goal and you are not relationally on the
same page on any of these decisions and
it's causing it's causing them to
multiply the problem instead of doing
away with you need to identify a clear
concise goal that the two of you are
willing to sacrifice to get to and that
means sell the truck and sell the camper
and it's the house county equity in it
it probably has a little bit of equity
in it but it's from you know we just
bought it in August so yeah I mean it
yeah and then we're gonna get on a tight
budget and we're not going out to eat
and we're not going on vacation we began
to attack this and as his income goes up
it's probably a five-year plan to pay
off $150,000 for the student loan debt
but until you get rid of this it's not
going to do anything but get worse
because income-based always goes with
negative amortization which means that
the interest is higher than the payments
you're paying so you're going backwards
and exactly just it's it's financial
suicide and yeah and the fact that you
cannot seem to get on the same page and
i don't know i'm i don't know whether
i'm hearing fear from him or arrogance
from him or maybe both but the way
you're describing the decision-making
the way you all interact it's not
healthy and so you guys got some work to
do on that to get on the same page I
really can't help you unless both of you
want to do something because what you
can't cut cable and fix this right you
can't not go to Starbucks and fix this
this is going to require a Hercule it's
a huge mess and it's are going to
require a unified approach between the
two of you to be able to win financially
because you know when one of you goes
and makes a decision then the other one
grabs the wheel and course corrects your
jumping back and forth from stupid is
stupid and really magnifying this mess
I'm sorry for you I know you're scared
but I'm I mean the fact that you guys
can't sit and have a good conversation
and come to a good conclusion to the
point that you're you know on a national
radio show crying tells me something
about y'all's relationship and that
that's scaring ya that's scaring me so
the two of you need to work on that I
I'm gonna send you to marriage
counseling first is what I'm gonna do
and when you get back from that if you
want to go through Financial Peace
University Kelly you Kelly's gonna pick
up she'll get your contact information
and you can contact her at that point
and then I will be happy to pay for you
to go through Financial Peace University
but I don't want you going to Financial
Peace University by yourself because
you're gonna end up divorcing this guy
if you do and that's and I don't want to
cause that that's not that's not where I
want to go because you're gonna start
having real firm knowledge based
opinions and and he's not gonna play
that for that this has got he's got to
be in on the idea and you guys got me
have to have a unified front
on where you're going with this it's the
only way it's gonna work for you
so you need to sit down with your pastor
and start working on some of these
relationship issues to where he's as a
good husband he should be a whole lot
more concerned about how scared you are
than he is and willing to do something
about it if there was something I could
do for Sharon and she was this scared
100% of time I'm gonna do it and and you
know you truthfully you've got a right
to be afraid because this is a pretty
sizable mess and doing nothing about it
is not gonna bring you to a good place
so I'm so sorry you're facing this but
hold on and Kelly will pick up she'll
take your information then if you guys
come back from marriage counseling and
you want to go to FPU we will pay for it
I do not want you going by yourself
though that would be an unhealthy thing
for you guys right now hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips
from the show
[Music]
Oh
[Music]